اعلنت مفوضيه الاتحاد الاوروبي انها تتابع
بقلق ما تردد من انباء عن ظهور لقاحات
فايروس كورونا في السوق السوداء لقاحات
للبيع هل من مشتري
بعد انطلاق حمله التلقيح هنا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
150 ومن صديق على مئه عندما ذهبنا معه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفايزر واخرى على تطبيقات التواصل المشفره
التامه
[موسيقى]
لا علاقه عمل جيده وطويله انت قلت انك
تريد كميات كبيره
واسواق موازيه
تعرضت علينا شركه شراء كميات كبيره من
اللقاح بعد ان اخبرتنا انها شركه مصريه
ولها مقر في القاهره في هذا الفيلم تنقلنا
بين سبع دول حول العالم
وانا على ثقه باننا سيقدمونه لي هو
التطعيم الصحيح
المتعلق ببيع لقاحات فيروس كوفي
19/04
وبشكل فوري
قمنا بهندسه صفقات على الانترنت المظلم
والسوق الموازيه تمث
في تجاره اللقاحات عبر المنتديات الخفيه
والاسواق السوداء تتبعنا حركه الاموال
والدفع بالعملات الرقميه المشفره
تلك الاموال بدءا من عمليه الدفع ووصولا
الى نقطه تحويلها وصرفها كما رفعنا الغطاء
عن شركات تورطت في عمليات احتيال وواجهنا
شخصيات طالتها اصابع الاتهام
[موسيقى]
ولا اريد ان افعل اي شيء يخص اللقاحات
بعد ان وصفت بماضيه تجاره اللقاحات
يمكننا ان نعرف هذه التجاره بسوق الرمادي
لللقاحات لانه حقا سوق رمادي للغايه
[موسيقى]
2020 كان الموت قد غيب قرابه مليون
و800,000 شخص بسبب جائع كورولا
للتلاعب والاحتلال والتجاره غير القانونيه
في اللقاحات
نتساءل في هذا الفيلم كيف كان يمكن ايقاف
هذا التلاعب والاحتيال والتجاره غير
القانونيه باللقاحات وهل كان بالامكان
حمايه المرضى من الوقوع في فخ الاحتلال
وماذا فعلت الجهات المسؤوله لوقف التلاعب
والاحتيال في لقاحات كورونا ولماذا حدث
هذا التلاعب ومن المسؤول عنه وكيف يمكن
تنافي الطرق الم التي لتجاره اللقاحات غير
القانونيه في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
الى بلادنا كنت اشعر بفقدان الامل كانت
العضوي جديده وتنتشر بصوره هائله في
البلاد لذلك كان علي ان انقذ حياتي واقوم
باخذ اللقاح
في ذلك الوقت لم اكن اتخيل ماذا تقول اليه
الامور لقد ذهبت للتطعيم وانا على ثقه
بانم سيقدمونه لي هو التطعيم الصحيح الذي
يحصل عليه الجميع
ياسمين تصاحب عمل الحر فان علي ان اصارع
من اجل البقاء وذلك على خلاف من يعملون في
المؤسسات الحكوميه الذين يتوفر لهم كل شيء
اننا مثل كتاكيت تنبت في الظلام بحثا عن
طعامها
بشان عمليات توزيع للالقاحات زائفه تم
رصدها حول العالم منها تحذير نشر في
فبراير شباط من العام 2001
تم ضبطها في المكسيك وتحذير اخر بتاريخ 20
من اغسطس حول تداول الى قاحات زائفه في
دول بينها الهند وميانمار واوغندا في
الفتره بين يوليو تموز واغسطس من العام
ذاته كان ابرزها عمليه تطعيم الجماعيه
التي تمت في النصف الاخير من يونيو حزيران
عام 2001 بمستشفى كسوه الاوغنديا
اه في جيمز وايباندا موفيز يحكون لنا كيف
وقعوا فريسه سهله للاستغلال
انهم يجب علينا الذهاب الى مشفى كسوه حيث
يقدمون الخدمه العامه اظن ان مشفى كونولو
كانوا مخصصا للشخصيات المهمه فقط
[موسيقى]
كبيره من الناس
لاحقا ان اللقاح كان مزيفا
حصلت على الجرعه الاولى في البدايه
وكنت انوي الذهاب للحصول على الجرعه
الثانيه
والبرلمان ووسائل الاعلام ان اللقاح
الموجود في مستشفى كسوه كان زائفا وذلك
بعد ان اجرته وازاله الصحه بعض الاختبارات
على الاشخاص الذين اخذوا اللقاح بعد مرور
اسبوعين
وحتى يبدو ان الامر لا يقتصر فقط على
اوغندا انه يحدث في كل مكان
باجماله مبيعات يتجاوز 188 مليار يورو
سنويا تعد الادويه المزيفه هي القطاع
الاكثر ربحا في سوق البضائع المقلده والذي
يتجاوز حجمه 1.6,000,000
€ حيث يموت بسبب تلك الادويه نحو مليون
شخص سنويا وفقا لتقرير سابق في دبليو سي
في الاشهر الاولى من العام 2021 ومع بدء
تصنيع اللقاح تلقت العديد من دول العالم
عروض الاحتياليه لتوفير ملايين الجرعات ما
دفع البرلمان والمفوضيه الاوروبيه وكذلك
البرلمان الاسترالي للقيام بتحقيقات بشان
تلك العروض
التقينا ان علي نائب رئيس لجنه انفاذ
القانون بالبرلمان الاسترالي والتي اطلعت
على كافه التحقيقات
حدث عجز في توفر اللقاح في عده دول من
الدول الناميه ولكن ايضا حدث ذلك في الدول
المتقدمه
ولد في توفير اللقاح هنا في استراليا
بالطبع وجود هذا العجز في اللقاحات يخلق
طلبا وعندما يياس الناس فهم يتجهون الى
الانترنت المظلم والمصادر غير الرسميه بل
حتى المصادر الاجراميه للحصول على اللقاء
[موسيقى]
في منتصف مارس اذار من العام 2021 فتح
الادعاء العام الايطالي عدد من التحقيقات
المتعلقه بمحاولات توريد ملايين الجرعات
من لقاح فيروس كورونا بشكل غير قانوني
كانت ابرزه تلك المحاولات ما شهده اقليم
لمبرجينيا الاقليم الاكثر تضررا من
الجارحه وقتها ما دفعنا للتوجه نحو مدينه
ميلانو عاصمه الاقليم في محاوله مواجهه
الاشخاص الذين اشير اليهم في تلك
التحقيقات
قابلنا القنصل الفخرى لدوله ناميبيا
بترجوهانسون كشف للمره الاولى تفاصيل ذكر
اسمه في صفقه لقاحات مثاره تساؤلات
قانونيه
ما حدث بالتحديد في هذه الواقعه ان احد
رجال الاعمال ذو الصلات القويه في ناميبيا
اخبرني انه على صله برجل اعمال بامكانه
توفير اللقاحات للسلطات الايطاليه
وان يرسل لي عرضا للسعر وانني ساقوم
بتنسيق هذه العلاقه
بطاقه
نحن هنا نتحدث بالطبع عن العروض وليست
اللقاحات نفسها ما نتحدث عنه وقيام شخص
وسيط بتقديم عرض للسلطات الرسميه لتوفير
كميات من اللقاحات الحقيقيه
ويخبرهم هذا الوسيط انه بمجرد ان يتسلم
الدفعه الماليه الاولى فان بامكانه ان
يرسل ملايين اللقاحات في اليوم التالي هذه
العروض عرضت على العديد من دول الاتحاد
ونحن ندرك جيدا ان هناك اغراءات كبيره
لقبول مثل هذه العروض
جديد سلمى
السلطات الايطاليه وبشكل فوري تعرفت على
رجل الاعمال هذا من خلال شخص اعرفه جيدا
لذلك لم يكن لدينا ادنى شك بانها صفقه
موثوقه
المباراه
بشكل مباشر كما ذكرت لها انه على تواصل مع
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه استراليا
وصلك رد منها لا لم اتلقى ايراد هل تلقيت
اي رد رسمي لا من اقليم لمبارديا لا لتيزي
موراتي
لم اتلقى اي رد من اي جهه ولم اقوم
بمتابعه الموضوع علمت بعدها ان سلطات
الاقليم قد قررت ابلاغ النائب العام انني
حاولت التوسط
ثم بدا التحقيق نعم وكان ذلك مفاجاه كبيره
حيث لم اكن اعلم ان ما فعلته كان امرا غير
قانوني لم اكن اعلم في ذلك الوقت ان تجاره
او عرض او اقتراح او حتى النقاشه في
اللقاحات هو امر غير قانونيه
كشفت الصحافه الايطاليه هويه رجل الاعمال
الذي قيل انه قدم العرض للقنصل اذ يدعس
كود داوسن فيلا وشهرته سكوتي وهو رجل
اعمال بلجيكي قدم عرضا للسلطات الايطاليه
في فبراير من عام 2021 وعاد فيه بتوفير
120 مليون جرعه من لقاح استرزنك بسعر قدره
12 دولار ونصف دولار للجرعه الواحده مضيفا
في نهايه الرساله الميزه تكمن في توافر
اللقاحات
تواصلنا مع سكوت عبر الهاتف وطلبنا منه
الرد على كلام القنصل الفخري الا انه نفع
علاقته بالامر رافضا اجراء مقابله
[موسيقى]
ليس لدي اي علاقه من لقاحات ولا اريد ان
ننخرط في اي شيء يخص اللقاحات لست مهتما
ولا اريد ان افعل اي شيء بخصوصها
لم تكن صفقه القنصل الفخري لناميبا هي
العمليه الوحيده التي شهدتها الاراضي
الايطاليه اذا اشارت اصابع الاتهام الى
مجموعه اكسور القابضه والتي كانت طرفا في
اتصالات مشوهه كادت توقيعها في عمليه
احتلال دوليه
الرئيس التنفيذي لاكسور القابضه على
الحديث معنا حيث كشف لنا في شهادته عن
تفاصيل تلك الصفقه انطلقت من احد اهم
العواصم العربيه
من جميع انحاء العالم قدمت لنا شركه
المصريه جميع اوراق الاعتماد الخاصه بها
والتي تتوافق مع شروط الوكاله السويسريه
للمنتجات العلاجيه في جسمك
الغرفه التجاريه والملف التعريفيه للشركه
همم وقد كان ثريا للغايه هو مليئا
باتصالات مهمه جدا مع شركات الادويه
الكبرى مثل شركه فايزر واي بوت وما الى
ذلك عرضت علينا شركه شراء كميات كبيره من
اللقاح بعد ان اخبرتنا انها شركه مصريه
ولها مقر في القاهره اجريت ثلاث مكالمات
جماعيه واجتماعان عبر تطبيق زوم مع رئيس
دوله في امريكا الوسطى وتحملت مسؤوليه
الامر كانت الشركه المصريه تحمل اوراق
اعتماد ممتازه
عن اثارت لدينا شكوكو حول موقفها الملك
نحن هنا نتحدث عن صفقه بمابالغ ضخمه كنا
نتحدث عن مليون جرعه من اللقاح فنحن هنا
امام صفقه تبلغ نحو 20 مليون يورو
طلب
مع الشركه في القاهره كانت 30 ردود مثيره
لشك مره ان المدير على سفر وتارتنا انه
مريض واخرى انه مصاب بكرانا شعارنا
بالريبه وادركنا انه لا توجد مكاتب في
القاهره وامام هذا وجدت انه من واجب
الابلاغ عن محاوله الاحتلال لم يكن
بالقاهره اعتقد انها كانت جرعات مزيفه
لانها جاءت من سلسله المجهوله من
التوريدات كنا مضينا قدما في الحديث عن
العقود كلما زادت التعقيدات حول امكانيه
تنفيذ الصفقه كان من غير الممكن ان اخاطر
برخصه بعد ان صادفت انشطه احتياليه لذا
ابلغت عنها ثم وصلت العمل فخر كوني تمكنت
من الحفاظ على سوقنا في
القطاعنا البحث حول حقيقه الشركه المصريه
التي تحدث عنها في شهادته من خلال احد
المصادر المتطلع على التحقيقات استطعنا
الحصول على عدد من وثائق القضيه ومن بينها
عرض للبيع صادر عن شركه تحمل اسم انفجر
تشير الاوراق ان مقرها يقع في مدينه
القاهره الجديده وفقا لتلك الوثيقه فقد
عرضت الشركه بيع اثنين مليون جرعه من لقاح
فايزر يتم شحنها من مصر الى المانيا مقابل
للجرعه الواحده كشفت الوثيقه ان عمليات
التحويل تتم لفائده حساب شخص في البنك
العربي السويسري باسم كريم نخله والذي
تبين انه عضو بمجلس اداره شركه
يظهر الموقع الالكتروني للشركه انها تمارس
انشطه وصفت بالرائده في مكافحه كوفي 19
فضلا عن توزيع اللقاحات في الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا وانها بائع او وكيل عده شركات
طبيه ابرزها فايزر ومدير
على مدى عده اسابيع حاولنا التواصل مع
انفينشر عبر الهاتف والبريد الالكتروني
دون رد الى ان تلقينا بريدا من السيد كريم
نخله يطلب فيه اجراء مكالمه هاتفيه لتوضيح
موقفه من تلك العروض نفى نخله في المكالمه
صحه تلك الاوراق
دي حاجه مش طالعه من عندنا ثاني حاجه
اي كلام في الهوى وبسؤاله عما اذا كان
يملك حسابا في البنك العربي السويسري كانت
الاجابه بالنفي
ما عندكش حساب في البنك العربي السوري
خالص
اخبرنا نخله برقم الحساب الذي ورد في
الوثيقه
الرقم بتاعه عشان مش حافظ الرقم وبسؤال عن
حقيقه تقديم شركته لتلك العروض نفى كريم
نخله صلته او شركته بها مؤكدا ان شركته
ليس لديها اي نشاط تجاري مع ايطاليا والمح
انه ربما يكون بعض الموظفين في شركته من
تورط في ذلك وانه سيجري تحقيقا داخليا
بهذا الشان احنا النهارده
احنا برده مشيناها من عندنا كانت بليز
موجوده همم وكان اذا بدك همم تعملوا مع
اطراف اللي هي احنا ما وافقناش نتعامل
معها ونذهب لك يعني نحن برده نبص على كل
الحاجات دي وناخذ الاكشن المضبوطه هاعمل
برده التحقيق داخلي ونشوف ممكن ناس من
اللي احنا ماشيينهم ولا ناس من كل الناس
دي نقدر نشوف ايه اللي بيحصل
قد نفى خلال المكالمه امكانيه قيام اي
شركه خاصه ببيع لقاحات فايزر
ده مش هنبيعه للشركات الخاصه وهو الامر
الذي اكدته فايزر في ردها على لجنه انفاذ
القانون بالبرلمان الاسترالي خلال تحقيقها
بشان عمليات الاحتلال المتعلق بلقاح
كورونا اكدت فيها فايزر انه لا يمكن شحن
لقاحها من اي دوله الا من خلال مصانعها في
بلجيكا والولايات المتحده وان عمليات
التعاقد
يتم الا عبر الموزعين المعتمدين
اعلنت مفوضيه الاتحاد الاوروبي انها تتاب
ع به سوق
السوق خلال اعمالنا في ايطاليا تحدث الينا
مصدر صحفي عن شركه تدعى اتريم ميديكال
يمتلكها رجل الاعمال الايطالي كريستيانو
غالي
تقدمت بعروض لعدد من الحكومات الاوروبيه
لبيع اللقاح قمنا بمخاطبه الشركه بعد ان
تخفينا في هويه شركه طبيه خاصه حيث طلبنا
توفير 50,000 جرعه من لقاح سبوتنيك
الروسيه جاء الرد ليؤكد روايه المصدر
الصحفي حيث قالت الشركه بامكانيه توفير
اللقاح بسعر 22 دولار ونصف الدولار للجرعه
الواحده طلبنا من الشركه تاكيد امكانيه
التوريد فجاءنا رد كريستيانو بامكانيه
ابرام الصفقه مع شركه خاصه وتمريرها على
انها مساعدات انسانيه من خلال مكتبهم في
موسكو بالتنسيق مع شركه حاصله على تفويض
لشحن الجرعات الامر الذي كشف وجها جديدا
للتلاعب في اقي الرسميه لتجاره اللقاحات
قررنا مواجهه ايتيل تريم مريكل تواصلنا
عبر الهاتف مع كريستيانو زغاره بشان العرض
الذي تقدمت به شركه
عن هذا الامر قبل شهرين تقريبا لقد مضى
وقت طويل
كتبنا كريستيانو بناء على طلبه رد شارحا
القواعد العامه لتجاره اللقاحات متراجعا
عن تاكيده بتنفيذ الصفقه في صوره مساعدات
انسانيه عبر شركه خاصه مؤكدا ان المشتري
يجب ان تكون الحكومه نفسها
[موسيقى]
لم تكن الاسواق السوداء والموازيه وحدها
هي التي تعرض كميات كبيره من الجرعات خارج
الاطر القانونيه اذ تردد مصطلح الانترنت
المظلم واسم تطبيق تيليجرام خلال رحلتنا
في تتبع المتهمين في هذه التجاره غير
المشروع
راقبنا خلال اكثر من 10 اشهر عروضا لبيع
اللقاحات على متاجر الانترنت المظلم والتي
كانت ما تلبث ان تختفي على متجر لتعاود
الظهور على متاجر اخرى بغرض الافلات من
الملاحقه القانونيه
وكب الفيلم عمليه التخفي المتسارعه ووثق
وراقب العروض بهدف تتبع حركه المبالغ
الماليه المدفوعه لشراء اللقاحات اجرينا
معاملتين علامتاجره تبيع لقاحات عبر
الانترنت المظلم كانت المعامله الاولى
لشراء عينات بقيمه
240$ يتم دفعها من خلال عمله البيتكوين
لاحظنا فيها تنقل الاموال بين اربع محافظ
الكترونيه مختلفه حتى استقرت في حساب على
منصه تداول الامريكيه بولونيكس والتي قامت
بنقل عملياتها الى برمودا بعد شبهات ماليه
العمليه الثانيه كانت على احد متاجر
الانترنت المظلم والتي لاحظنا فيها تنقل
الاموال بين ثلاثه محافض الكترونيه مختلفه
حتى استقرت في النهايه في محفظه بيتكوين
خاصه بشركه تحمل اسم بي تي سي جلوبل
وبالبحث تبين انها شركه جنوب افريقيا يجري
التحقيق معها في اتهامات بالاحتيال
بالتزامن مع بدايه حاله الطوارئ الوبائيه
في اوروبا كانت الوحده الخاصه بالاحتيال
التكنولوجي في الشرطه الايطاليه تنسق مع
مكتب المدعي العام في ميلانو لتبدا عمليه
امنيه كبرى حملت اسم فاكس 3 بغرض ملاحقه
التجاره غير القانونيه في لقاحات فيروس
كورونا والتي كشفت عن كميات كبيره من
جرعات مزيفه كان يتم بيعها للجمهور عن
طريق تطبيق تيليجرام قبل ان تصادر في
الفتره بين ابريل نيسان ويوليو تموز من
عام 2021
دفعنا هذا للتوجه نحو العاصمه الايطاليه
روما حيث التقينا قائد وحده الاحتلال
التكنولوجي في الشرطه الايطاليه ليكشف لنا
كواليس تلك العمليه
تعد حملته رقص فري عمليه مع تماما مقارنه
بالانشطه التقليديه الاخرى فهي لا تستند
على شكوى او تقارير من قبل اشخاص معينين
اذ نشات من خلال عمليات مراقبه التي
اجريناها كاس في شرطه الجرائم الماليه فمن
خلال برمجيات اليه متطوره واحدث التقنيات
التعرف على الصور عبر الانترنت
رصدنا عددا من المتاجرين باللقاحات فضلا
عن شهادات التطعيم المزيفه ما قادنا
لتنفيذ هذه العمليه الكبيره حيث قمنا في
المرحله الاولى بحجم تلك القنوات التي
تعلن عن هذه اللقاحات وعن بيع الشهادات
المزينه
والتي تبيع من خلالها قنوات التلجرام
لقاحات المزيفه بدعوه تبعيتها لشركات
الادويه الكبرى
عن شهادات التطعيم والمنتجات المتعلقه
بالجائحه المستجدات
شرطه اقتصاديه وماليه فقد اهتممنا على
الفور بهذه الامور المتعلقه بتجارتها
هؤلاء المجرمين كان الامر واضحا بمحاولتهم
الاستفاده من تلك الحاله الطارئه كانت
مهمه قنوات التليجرام الترويج والدعايه
لتلك العروض للبيع بعد ذلك يتم توجيه
الراغبين للشراء الى ما يسمى بالانترنت
المظلم
توجهنا لنقابل احد الخبراء في شركه كاسبر
سكاي المتخصصه في الامن السيبراني كي نحصل
على معلومات اكثر حول تجاره اللقاحات على
الانترنت المظلم ديمتري جالوف احد اعضاء
فريق البحث والتحليل بالشركه يكشف لنا عن
تفاصيل تتبعه لاكثر من 15 مجرا على
الانترنت المظلم تعرض عليها لقاحات للبيع
كل الانشطه المتعلقه به ونرصد الطرق التي
يحاول بها العديد من المجرمين استغلال تلك
الجائحه ومع تصدر انباء الوباء للاخبار
اقدم المحتالون على استخدام الرسائل
التصيد الاحتيالي وغيرها من الوسائل في
وقت لاحق رصدنا انشطه جديده تمثلت في
تجاره اللقاحات عبر المنتديات الخفيه
والاسواق السوداء في البدايه قمنا تحليل
ما يقارب 15 سوقا من المتاجر المشهوره على
الانترنت المظلم رصدنا عروضا لبيع انواع
مختلفه من اللقاحات مثل استرازينيكا
ومودرن وفايزر
لمعرفه كيفيه تبادل الاموال على تلك
الاسواق توجهنا نحو العاصمه البولنديه
وارسو لطلب مساعده شركه كوين فيرم
المتخصصه في تحليلات واداره مخاطر العملات
المشفره والتي تعد الطريقه الرئيسيه
لاتمام تلك المعاملات
المتعلقه باللقاحات الزائفه على الانترنت
حول العالم
المياه اللينك السوداء
لا يمكننا المخاطره بشراء لقاح زائف لان
هذا قد يتم اعتبارهم خراطا في عمليه
التجاره غير الشرعيه ولكن يمكننا بالطبع
فحص المنتجات الاخرى التي يعرضها نفس
البائعين
رودريج مراد هارست استاذ علم الجريمه واحد
الخبراء الذين تم الاستعانه بهم اثناء
تحقيق البرلمان الاسترالي حول النشاطات
المشبوهه التي تتعلق بلقاحات كورونا
يخبرنا عن خطوات عمليات شراء اللقاحات
داخل الانترنت المظلم
على الانترنت المظلم الامر بسيط يمكنني
فعل ذلك كما لو كنت اشتري من البيت كل ما
تحتاجه هو النقر على المنتج لتصل الى صفحه
اخرى تجد فيها طريقه التواصل مع البائع
ويتم التواصل عاده من خلال معرف تشفير خاص
يتم استخدامه للتواصل معه عبر تطبيقات
اخرى مثلا قد يستخدم بعضهم البريد
الالكتروني المشفره مثل بروتو ثم يخبرك
بعدها بمعرفه العمله الالكترونيات التي
يستخدمها لاستقبال التحويلات وعندما يستلم
الاموال يقوم باتمام الصفقه ويتم التسليم
ما يحدث عاده في هذه الاصوات وهي اسواق
منظمه الى حد كبير فان عمله البيتكوين
التي ارسلها لن تذهب مباشره
بالقيمه لحين اتمام المعامله
[موسيقى]
زائفا على الانترنت المظلم فانه يقوم
بالدفع من خلال بيتكوين او اي عمله مشفره
اخرى هذه العمليه تظهر على الشبكات العامه
على تلك المبالغ فانهم يقومون بصرف تلك
العملات المشفره عبر منصه التداول
المختلفه تستطيع انظمهنا تتبع تلك الاموال
بدءا من عمليه الدفع ووصولا الى نقطه
تحويلها وصرفها همم
التحويلات وهذه تعد معلومات قيمه جدا
للسلطات القانونيه لانها تمكنهم من التعرف
على هؤلاء المحتاليه
الجنرايت
ضد مخاطر غسيل الاموال وذلك لاحد حسابات
البيتكوين التي وجدناها على الانترنت
المظلم كما ترون على الشاشه هذه الدوائر
تمثل عناوين البلوكشن المرتبطه بشكل ما
بلقاحات كوفي 19 مزوره
اي نشاط منهم ومن ثم تتبع الاموال الصادره
من ذلك العنوان
بشكل تلقائي وبعض هذه الاموال استقرت في
النهايه في منصات التداول عالميه شهيره
بلاك ماركه
الاتصالات واتمام المعاملات الماليه عبر
العملات المشفره على سوق الانترنت المظلم
يتم الضمان السريه التامه اثناء شراء هذه
المنتجات
اللقاحات تباع باسعار مختلفه فقد عرضت
بمتوسط السعر يتراوح بين 180 و 200 دولار
وقد رصدنا صفقات وصل سعرها حتى 20,000
يورو في بعض الحالات لم نتمكن من رصد
عمليات الشحن الحقيقي بعد الشراء حتى في
المرات النادره التي كانت تصل فيها شحنات
كانت جرعاتها زاحفه لم يكن الامر يعد كونه
احتيانا لم تكن هناك لقاحات ترسل في
الواقع عبر هذه القنوات على الاطلاق
حاولنا الحصول على رد من تطبيق تيليجرام
حول الاجراءات التي اتخذوها لمنع هذه
النشاطات لكن وحتى تاريخي بث هذا التحقيق
لم يصلنا اي رد
لمركب جهاز تمدد تلك الاسواق اكثر واكثر
لقد رصدنا عروضا للقاحات بدءا من 200
دولار وحتى 2000 دولار للجرعه الواحده
وفقا للمعلومات المعروضه والمتاحه للعامه
تظهر هذه المواقع ان هناك بائعين نجحوا في
اتمام ما يقارب 500 عمليه بيع ناجحه
قويه
بيع حقيقيه في متاجر الانترنت
لدينا العديد من الحالات التي حاول فيها
اشخاص
ثم تبين انهم محتالون قد يقومون بارسال
عبوات بها ماء او اي محلول اخر حتى هذه
اللحظه لم نرى اي اثبات لشخص قام بشراء
لقاح من خلال الانترنت المظلم وتاكد من
صحته كما اننا قمنا بالعديد من المحاولات
لشراء لقاحات زائفه
حاتم فقط وذلك بهدف اختبارها ولكن في كل
مره قمنا بذلك لم يصلنا اي لقلقه
عمليات البحث والمقابلات التي اجريناها
اكد الخبراء ان العروض المنتشره على
الانترنت المظلم هي عمليات واحتيال
احترافيه تنتهي بالحصول على المال دون
ارسال اي لقاحات تذكر
قمنا باختبار ذلك حيث توصلنا مع احد
التجار الموجودين على تطبيق تيليجرام لطلب
جرعات من اللقاح
تخفينا في صوره شركه معدات طبيه تعقد صفقه
مع التاجر لتوفير خمسه الاف جرعه بغرض
تصديرها لدوله اسيويه شريطه ان نتسلم
درعتين في البدايه لتحليلهما مخبريه
عمل جيده وطويله انت قلت انك تريد كميات
كبيره وانا مهتم بذلك
على ذلك وطلب منا ان ندفع له ثمن الجرعتين
عبر حسابه على بيت كوين
قمنا بالتحويل وارسلنا اليه ما يفيد بذلك
عاد تاجر ليطلب ثمن ثلاث جرعات اخرى بحجه
انه لا يمكنه شحن اقل من خمس جرعات
[موسيقى]
يمكنني ان اقبل ببيبال لكنه معقد بعض
الشيء بيتكون سيكون افضل طلبنا منه ان
يقوم بشحن الجرعات الخمس اولا حتى نستكمل
ارسال المبلغ المتبقي
كما اخبرتك سابقا انا في انتظارك عندما
تكمل عمليه السداد سارسل لك رقم التعقد
وبالفعل تلقينا بريدا من شركه شحن تحمل
اكسبريس
الشحن وانها في الطريق الينا انتظرنا وصول
الجرعات لكن لا شيء لم يصل في الوقت ذاته
استمر التاجر في المطالبه بثمن الجرعات
الثلاث مدعيا قيامه بشحن الجرعات الخمس
بمزيد من البحث تبين لنا ان اكس
شركه شحن وهميه صنع موقعها بشكل احترافي
بغرض انتحال صفه شركه اخرى تدعى اكسبريس
من لوجستيك حاولنا التواصل مع التاجر
لمواجهته بذلك الا انه اغلق كل وسائل
التواصل معنا
وامنوا ان يكون سبب ذلك وعيون الناس بان
هناك احتماليه كبيره ان يتم الاحتلال
عليهم
لانها تجاره عابره للقارات فاين تتبعها
وملاحقه المتورطين فيها يعد امرا في غايه
الصعوبه وحتى ان تم الوصول اليهم فان حجم
العقبات الاجرائيه والقانونيه تشكل عائقا
كبيرا في مثولهم للعداله
[موسيقى]
جرائم الانترنت حيث تخضع الضحيه لسلطه
قضاء ماء بينما يخضع المجرم لسلطه قضاء في
منطقه ثانيه والمال يخضع لسلطه قضاء في
منطقه ثالثه ولذلك ما نحتاجه هو تعاون
ثلاث سلطات مختلفه على الاقل وهذا في
الحقيقه ليس امرا سهلا ويزداد الامر سوءا
اذا كان ضحايا موزعين على عده دول مختلفه
اذا فالحل الواقعي هو وجود تنسيق دولي
عالي المستوى لانفذ القانون واظن ان تنفيذ
ذلك سيكون امرا ممكن في بعض الدول انه في
دول اخرى لذا ينشط معظم مجرمين الانترنت
في الولايات القضائيه التي لا تطولهم فيها
يد العداله
هذا عدد كبير دعني احدثك بالارقام وصل عدد
جرعات اللقاح المعروضه الى واحد فاصل
اثنين مليار لقاح وبالنسبه لقيمه العروض
فقط وصلت الى
16.4 مليار يورو معظم هذه العروض كانت تصل
من هو للثالثه لذا فان عمليات تتبع تلك
الشركات والتحقق منه هويتها كان امرا صعبا
ستاند فروستوس
[موسيقى]
ف
لقد كشفت جائتك كورونا عن ارتباك عالميه
اسهم في خلق نشاط احتياليا بشان اللقاحات
وهو ما قد يتكرر اذا ما ظهرت متحورات
فيروسيه جديده في المستقبل هل تعلمت حكومه
العالم من دروس كورونا القاسيه وهل طورت
اليات الكفءه للانذار المبكر والتعامل
الفوري مع الثغرات التي ينفذ منها هؤلاء
المحتالون وهل ستتحمل الحكومات مسؤولياتها
في وصول الخدمات الصحيه بشكل امن وفعال
للاشخاص الذين يتوجب رعايتهم
دي الشمس
تقارير التي تلقيناها حتى الان الى خطوره
المشكله وتؤكد على ضروره وجود مؤسسات قويه
وقوانين فعاله للتصدي لها
ايضا ونحن ننظر الى التداعيات الصحيه 19
ان نفكر في التداعيات الامنيه
[موسيقى]
اعتاقي معك
اصاب الجميع وما من احد الا وتاثر سلبا
بتلك الجائحه يجب ان لا يستغلها هؤلاء
الناس حاجه الاخرين الماسه لاخذ اللقاح
يجب ان يتوقفوا
[موسيقى]